no reference Dragonball Vegeta hey guys
welcome to no reference Dragonball where
are you draw a Dragon Ball characters
from memory with no reference the first
one we're doing today is Vegeta and
there's going to be a bunch more so stay
tuned I like to draw things and so as
you can see I'm starting off drawing the
face make him look like a cross boy
yeah Vegeta's cross the toughest thing I
think about drawing Dragon Ball
characters is getting the face shape
correct and I only recently found out
that the jaw cheekbone kind of thing
should be around the level of the mouth
so that's helped me a lot also you might
notice that I'm drawing these guys front
on all the time and that's because I'm
extremely lazy and I don't want to have
to draw more than I need to also as the
holidays and I was desperate for content
so here we are I'm just making sure that
the line worked for Vegeta is correct
here I've giving him a nice little brow
furrow getting the lines nice and
straight
his nose is giving me a bit of trouble
but I get there I draw his mouth and I
make him across again you'll notice that
the the jaw seems to be kind of weird so
I just decide you know what I'm gonna
cut this in half and go to cut my losses
short and here it is it looks okay I
think yeah so gotta draw the ears I love
drawing ears I can draw ears and like no
time flat and you can see I just copied
and pasted the other ear in theater
sight this is the beauty of doing a
front view shot so I don't need to do
more work than I actually need to yeah
so I'm making him have a nice receding
hairline because I make really the
Dragon Ball character is like a Goku and
Vegeta like look the exact same I mean
if you give Goku an angry face he has
the exact same face as Vegeta the only
thing that makes them different is the
hair so I decided to give Vegeta a nice
big bushy hair yeah so kind of have it
kind of like spread out from the bottom
and get nice and thick in the middle so
we're drawing his his his his collarbone
so you think it's a dragon ball you can
either draw a collarbone or you can just
draw boobs I
to draw the collarbone because I think
it looks cooler but I know some people
like to draw the pecs only and that's
fine I kind of I do both it's just today
I felt a bit more like collarbone guy
than a boobs guy so I'm drawing his
armor and you know doing pretty low
detail but you know all at all with no
reference from memory it's it's it's
okay Vegeta I mean I could draw better
with reference but I mean like just
looking at it as it is it's I think it's
okay you know just filling in the gaps
because I'm gonna do a little trick here
where I go to select things and it
automatically colors the area for me
again because I'm extremely lazy and the
trick to drawing is learning how to draw
with as with as little effort as
possible so I'm like okay you might be
thinking to yourself okay mark this is a
very very blue I'm not sure if this is
gonna work or not but your thing is that
if you actually use the shine and the
shading correctly it actually changes
the texture and color of the suit or its
appearance of color I suppose so I think
that looks pretty okay as Vegeta goes
there is it's pretty good I'm getting is
nice little bit of shading I think that
works what do you guys think did I get
Fujita did I not get Fujita oh yeah this
is great commentary so yeah the shading
looks good I or at least I think it
looks good that's Vegeta what do you
guys think did I nail him did I not nail
him
no homo okay next one I'm gonna I'm
gonna drawing piccolo I've never drawn
piccolo before and I soon realized that
you can't draw a piccolo the same way
you could you can draw the other guys so
you look at that you think man
that looks just awful the one thing I
knew about drawing piccolo is that I
knew that his kind of eye brow furrow
things are out further than his head
shape so I kind of worked with that I
need to make that mouth smaller I'm not
sure how I can do that but we're getting
there we're getting there slowly okay so
that looks okay so I decided okay cut my
losses short and just start drawing his
scarf thing to hide his face
so okay go draw his like scarf Ascot
whatever the thing is and he's gonna
kind of hide his face drawing his ears
was fun because it's a weird shape and
you can pretty much use the exact same
principle for a normal ear but you just
stretch it out and we're loose like that
that's what I do I'm not sure if that's
the right way to do things
artists is that the right way to do
things I'm not sure so I'm gonna give
him a turbine kind of thing that he
wears because again that hides his
antenna that I don't want to bother
drawing again drawing is all about
taking shortcuts and being as lazy as
you possibly can so yeah I actually
thought the clothing in this the turned
out way better than I expected it to so
yeah again this is my very first time
drawing piccolo and I thought it turned
out pretty good I mean like looking I
mean so far it's it's it's okay I mean I
haven't put the colors down yet and I'm
like I I've seen these characters all
the time for ages and I'm like you know
I think I got a good idea of what these
characters look like so I decided to go
and get adventurous I'm like I'm gonna
give him his big shoulder pad thing with
the cape and I'm like has a lot of sure
are a lot of like creases and foldings
and then I hope I get that right so I'm
not sure if I did get this right or not
because it looks looks okay but I'm not
sure exactly where it falls or how it
works so I'm hoping this is where it is
but yeah this is pretty much my piccolo
I'm gonna color him now and I'm gonna go
for a nice that's very great okay it's
better I was worried there for a second
no this looks this looks relatively okay
I
oh I think I remember I remember
thinking when this was done that maybe I
made the coat to gray because it's
supposed to be white obviously but I
think they kind of wanted it to be I
don't know I kind of wanted to have more
of a contrast with the shading colors
and I was hoping that would make it look
more white but it didn't really so I
think it's just a tad too gray shading
on the face is alright though I mean at
least it looks like piccolo but uh yeah
I don't know I think from my very first
time ever drawing piccolo this is okay I
mean I've it could have been way worse
and I was surprised I was able to get it
so
okay I guess I mean what do you guys
think I mean I don't want to say this is
a good drawing because it's my very
first time drawing pic alone and I could
definitely do better but in terms of no
reference from memory I think it's
pretty okay I don't know
hey piccolo okay next next we have Goku
and he's my favorite character and I've
drawn him about a thousand times so if I
screw this up then I really can't call
myself an artist or I don't like I
really can't call myself good or at
least competent at drawing there that's
better so we're drawing Goku and as you
can see his eyes are different to
Vegeta's and that's pretty much the only
difference so also he's smiling Vegeta
doesn't really smile unless he's angry
or at least has angry eyes but this is
Goku he looks like a nice little pretty
boy I get the JA perfect in one go
because I'm a perk so here we go we got
drawing the ears because here's a fun
and easy to draw drawing his hair it's
done his mouth is fixed thank God that
was bothering me um yeah so this is Goku
again same principle as Vegeta here we
go draws hair I always find these three
spikes really difficult I don't know
what it is I always it just it never
looks right to me like and then I did
and then I wouldn't shot the other side
like I don't understand
Goku's hair is weird one side for me is
super easy to draw the other side is
just super I don't know it looks wrong
to me but when it's all together it
looks fine I guess so the clothes are
fun to draw Goku there's a lot of little
creases and you know just follow the
shape of his body and stuff I think I
got the body right like I think it looks
okay for some reason I had I feel like I
should have drawn the body first and
then the clothes but for some reason I
was in a rush so here's that I'm also
giving him a really tanned complexion or
at least tan compared to the anime the
reason why I'm doing this is because
Toriyama has old colors for Goku were
like he was pretty tan and I like that
look I think it works well with the
orange key so this is why he he's quite
10 and if you're wondering that's why so
yeah I'm gonna go for a lighter blue
here and
I'm hoping that when I add the shading
that these colors won't look as vibrant
and bright so let's see if that works so
I go for a dark orange and look it kind
of it neutralizes the bright orange a
bit not as much as I wanted to but you
know it's from memory so whatever that's
going to be my excuse and I'm sticking
to it so I think it works a bit better
with the it's very turquoise should it
be that turquoise okay but you know what
I'm happy with the skin tone for Goku I
think it looks cool the shading so far
looks pretty good on the skin actually
yeah you can see I'm kind of like making
it up as I go I'm kind of going over
places erasing some parts and and
maintaining you know others but you know
what so far for no for no reference
completely from memory it looks pretty
okay I'm happy with that I mean are you
happy with that I hope you're happy with
that because this has been the video and
here we are with Goku and I'm drawing
him and he's done what do you guys think
leave your thoughts in the comments down
below should I do more of this kind of
stuff I don't know maybe see you next
week bye